tf à 20h avec roger gicquel le prix
nobel de la paix 77 à amnesty
international qu'ils dénoncent les
atteintes aux droits de l'homme ça use
ça use
un rendez vous manqué les soviétiques
trahis par leur électronique le budget
78 demain l'assemblée nationale pour la
première fois les commerçants et
artisans pourront bénéficier des mêmes
abattements fiscaux que les salariés de
deux francs 17 à 84 centimes
la pomme de terre légumes de luxe en
1976 redevient un produit bon marché
la mini transat 25 coquille de noix à
l'assaut de l'atlantique
deux prix nobel de la paix ont donc été
décerné aujourd'hui à stockholm l'un
pour l'année 76 où il n'avait pas été
attribués il va à 2 irlandaise betty
williams 34 ans et mes rides corrigan 24
ans qui fondèrent le mouvement des
femmes irlandaises pour la paix à
belfast
en outre 76 le second nobel de la paix a
été attribué pour 77 à une organisation
qui a su s'imposer dans la lutte pour
les droits de l'homme en dehors de toute
considération politique
cette appréciation est de andreï
sakharov lui même lauréat du même prix
en 75 ainsi donc les jury du nobel n'ont
pas récompenser des vedettes ou des
personnalités politiques cette année
mais des mouvements qui ont pris comme
bannière la protestation contre la
violence et la générosité pour ces
victimes organisations de volontaires
elles ont appris la patience et
l'efficacité
amnesty international comme les femmes
irlandaises pour la paix ne se sont pas
laissé impressionner par une tâche qui
peut paraître impossible
elles ont montré que l'esprit pacifique
peut triompher s'il est convaincu de sa
force
amnesty international par exemple sa
création remonte à 16 ans
l'organisation qui s'est occupé d'abord
des prisonniers politiques et qui combat
également la peine de mort et d' usage
de la torture peut présenter un bilan
largement positif
elle réserve son aide à ceux qui n'ont
pas employer la violence ou ne l'ont pas
recommandé aujourd'hui par exemple elle
dénonçait les
distant de plusieurs milliers de
prisonniers politiques en allemagne de
l'est et les changes de 1300 d'entre eux
contre des denrées rares
mais en même temps au moment où l'on
examinait la demande d'extradition de
l'avocat des extrémistes allemand klaus
croissant amnesty international demande
à la france de s'assurer des conditions
de détention des prisonniers politiques
en allemagne fédérale
nous sommes critiqués par un nombre de
plus en plus grand de gouvernement à
l'est comme à l'ouest a dit son
président et il faut reconnaître que la
plupart des pays qui sont représentés à
la conférence de belgrade ont tous d'une
façon ou d'une autre viol et la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
qu est-ce qu amnesty international quel
est son action
michel bader nul ne sera soumis à la
torture
nul ne peut être arbitrairement arrêté
détenu ou exilé
toute personne a droit à la liberté de
pensée tout individu a le droit de ne
pas être inquiété pour ses opinions
tels sont les objectifs l'homme le ch'ti
internationale ces objectifs ne sont pas
que le simple voeu exemple leonid pliage
lorsqu'ils descendent du train à vienne
en provenance d' union soviétique
quel est son premier mot merci merci à
amnesty international
même réaction pour les mêmes raisons de
la part de sandor arancibia l'un des
dirigeants socialistes qui venait de
quitter le chili c'est aussi la
suppression de l'aide militaire des
états unis à l'uruguay à la suite de la
campagne d'amnesty international
cette organisation fut créé en 1961 à
londres elle est consciente de ne
pouvoir faire respecter tous les droits
de l'homme elle pare au plus pressé
la torture la détention arbitraire la
liberté de pensée amnesty international
refuse et a déjà eu l'occasion de
refuser des subsides en provenance de
gouvernement l'église où le mouvement
politique
son budget de 700 millions de centimes
est due aux seules cotisations de ses
membres
dix mille en france 200 milles dans 70
pays du monde son principe de
fonctionnement on décerne à l'un des
membres de l'organisation un objectif
précis à lui d'entrer en contact avec un
prisonnier à l'huile obtenir sa
libération ou du
une amélioration de ses conditions de
détention en quelque sorte une
personnalisation de l'application des
droits de l'homme quant au mouvement des
femmes irlandaises pour la paix il a été
créé l'année dernière mais par une
poignée de femmes dont betty williams et
mairead corrigan qui avait on en avait
assez des violences dans leur pays après
deux marches pour la paix qui ont
rassemblé beaucoup de monde 8000
personnes une fois vingt mille l'autre
la fois d'après elles ont multiplié
leurs interventions à la télévision et
elles entretiennent des centres de
jeunes qui veulent quitter des
associations paramilitaires catholique
ou protestante sans risquer des
représailles
écoutez betty williams quand elle a
appris qu'elle avait le prix nobel
mes neveux et mes nièces et tous ceux
qui sont morts au cours des dix
dernières années ne sont pas morts en
vain
nous avons manifesté pour les mêmes
raisons que celles pour lesquelles il
était mort fait recette et sédières et
non servir un parti le 20e anniversaire
du début de la conquête de l'espace est
un peu ratée pour les soviétiques
le rendez vous qui devait avoir lieu cet
après midi entre soyouz 25 avec deux
hommes à bord et la station saliou ciss
a brusquement été annulés et l'équipage
est revenu sur terre pourquoi exactement
on ne le sait pas mais ce n'est pas la
première fois p soviétique connaissent
là haut
de tels ennuis la série noire qu'il
traversait il ya trois ans ne semble
donc pas terminée mort de trois
cosmonautes explosion d'une station
saliou et cetera michel chevalet nous
donne son explication
l'opération que les soviétiques devait
réaliser cet après-midi n'était ni plus
ni moins qu'un rendez-vous un nez à nez
entre deux véhicules le premier le
soyouz avec ici dans la cabine les deux
cosmonautes et puis la station orbitale
saliou ciss qui pèse rien moins que 19
tonnes et avec un volume de 100 mètres
cubes et l'opération est bien c'est
simplement un rendez vous seulement ce
rendez-vous procéda façon suivante toute
la première phase est automatique et les
200 derniers mètres et bien se font à la
main en quelque sorte en vol à vue
piloté par les deux cosmonautes et 7 à
ce moment là que les soviétiques ont
déclaré forfait pourquoi il y avons
trouvé d'explication il faut en quelque
sorte revenir en arrière remonter vingt
ans en arrière au début d'astronautique
au moment du lancement de spoutnik 1 à
cette époque les soviétiques disposait
d'un véhicule extrêmement puissant d'un
lanceur très puissant que vous voyez ici
la fusée rd7 sa conception est
caractéristique vous voyez que c'est une
fusée à structure pyramidale avec à la
base non pas un ou deux moteurs comme
les fusées américaines mais 20 moteurs
avec cet engin extrêmement puissants
qu'ils étaient capables de satelliser 4
tonnes en orbite autour de la terre dès
1957 les soviétiques ont pu s'offrir
toutes les grandes premières spatial
notamment un satellite d'une tonne 3 en
orbite automates r est le premier homme
en orbite autour de la terre khayarine
le 12 avril 61
ils purent le faire car ils ont
construit à cette époque une cabine
spatiale qui était une sphère que vous
voyez ici lors de son retour sur terre
une sphère très lourde très compact très
solide
al'inverse à cette époque-là en 1961 les
américains lancèrent john green le
premier astronaute américain avec cette
fusée la red stone dérivés d'une fusée
militaire que l'on doit à van den brande
et vous voyez que cette fusée est très
flux être très légère trois fois moins
puissante
à l'époque la fusée des soviétiques et
les américains durent faire donc léger
et très fiable en 1967 dix ans plus tard
toujours avec la même fusée les
soviétiques lancèrent leur premier
soyouz mais attention à ce moment là ils
furent tributaires de leurs fusées ils
durent faire très léger et très con
l'ex pour procéder à des rendez-vous
automatique que vous voyez entre le
soyouz et le sérieux et c'est à ce
moment là que commencèrent les déboires
soviétique
l'industrie ne suivit pas ils ne surent
pas faire léger et fiable en un mot ils
furent victimes de leur électronique
la moitié des français 50 % voteraient
aujourd'hui pour l'opposition de gauche
selon un sondage du figaro 15 47 %
voteraient pour la majorité et 3% pour
les écologistes la gauche a donc perdu
trois points dans ce sondage sofres qui
traduit le désappointement de beaucoup
de ses électeurs
la situation reste bloquée entre les
communistes et les socialistes ainsi le
bureau politique du parti communiste a
examiné a exprimé cet après midi sa
profonde déception et son inquiétude
aggravée après la réunion du comité
directeur socialiste qui selon charles
fiterman porte parole du pc n'a apporté
aucune ouverture aucun élément nouveau
la porte est toujours verrouiller a dit
charles fiterman le ps tourne à
semble-t-il la page de l'union a décidé
de se consacrer exclusivement à ses
ambitions électorales ces proclamations
unitaire ne sont qu'un rideau de fumée
fin de citation les communistes
réaffirment leur volonté d'aboutir à un
bon programme et j'apprends à l'instant
que gaston defferre a dit dans une
séance du conseil municipal à marseille
que lui il avait déjà le sentiment
depuis juillet que les communistes ne
signerait pas le programme commun
actualisé il avait même écrit à françois
mitterrand a qu'en termes galants ces
choses-là sont dites sur une feuille
habituellement rébarbative la feuille
d'impôt sur le revenu
et comme beaucoup aimeraient recevoir
une comme celle ci il s'agit d'un avis
de non imposition ou d'imposition non
mise en recouvrement tous les français
ressources modestes qui ont rempli leur
déclaration de revenus mais qui n'ont
pas d'impôt à payer recevront désormais
cet avis de non imposition
cette nouveauté sera à conserver
précieusement par ceux qui la recevront
elle leur permettra en effet de
justifier plus facilement leur niveau de
ressources pour obtenir les avantages
sociaux auxquels ils ont droit par
exemple minimum vieillesse l'aide
sociale la bourse d'études etc
surtout quand vous recevrez cette
feuille ne cherchait pas court bien vous
avez à payer puisqu'elle signifie que
vous
rien à payer et vous êtes prêt de 5
millions dans ce cas qu'il a recevront
avant la fin de l'année c'est demain que
commencera le marathon budgétaire à
l'assemblée nationale avant d'examiner
pendant deux mois les impôts puis les
dépenses prévues pour l'an prochain
les députés auront droit pour la rentrée
pourrait pour la première fois à une
présentation audiovisuelle du budget en
900 diapositives commentées
j'aurais bien voulu vous montrer ça mais
pour l'instant priorité aux députés et
puis mercredi c'est raymond barre qui
expliquera comment le budget sincère
dans sa politique économique d'ensemble
on maintiendra les écrous serré et
d'autre part ce projet de budget 78
prétend marqué un grand pas vers
l'égalité des français devant l'impôt
vous vous savez et cela intéresse
surtout les commerçants les artisans que
le gouvernement a admis le principe de
l'abattement de 20% pour ces catégories
comme pour les salariés
mais auparavant il voulait mieux
connaître les revenus qu'on appelle non
salariaux une solution a été trouvée
les non salariés bénéficieront dès l'an
prochain de l'abattement de 20% à la
condition qu'ils adhèrent un centre de
gestion agréé késako elle avait l'air
théoriquement plus d'un million de non
salariés pourront bénéficier l'an
prochain des mêmes avantages fiscaux que
les salariés les commerçants et artisans
dont le chiffre d'affaires est inférieur
à 1 million et demi de francs les
prestataires de services dont les
recettes ne dépasse pas quatre cent
cinquante mille 30 les membres de
professions libérales dont les recettes
sont inférieures à 425 mille une
condition adhérer à un centre de gestion
agréé par le ministère des finances
un cadeau la réponse se trouve ici
ce qui est expliqué aussi par une marge
commerciale
ils sont experts comptables leur rôle
analyser les documents comptables de
leurs adhérents leur donner des conseils
de gestion
un inspecteur des impôts vient les
assister deux fois par mois les
responsables économiques s'accordent
pour vanter les mérites de tel sens pour
y adhérer il faut opter pour
l'imposition sur le bénéfice réel même
si l'on a droit ou forfait il faut donc
tenir une comptabilité ce qui va bien
dans le sens de la modernisation du
commerce
et puis il faut s'engager à fournir tous
ses documents comptables
ce qui signifie en clair à ne pas
frauder seulement voilà
créé il y a deux ans les centres de
gestion n'ont pas eu beaucoup de succès
à peine plus de dix mille adhérents pour
toute la france
il est vrai que jusqu'à présent
l'avantagé fiscal était limitée à 10%
beaucoup estimaient que cela
compenserait à peine leurs nouveaux
frais de comptabilité avec l'abattement
fiscal porté à 20% le gouvernement
espère que le nombre des adhérents sera
au moins multiplié par dix
reste les réticences de ceux qui
craignent que l'inspecteur des impôts du
centre se livre à une acquisition
fiscale
le rôle de l'inspecteur des impôts et de
nous conseiller en particulier pour
éviter que les dossiers soient
insatisfaisant lors d'un contrôle fiscal
autrement dit c'est pour assurer la
sécurité de l'adhérent beaucoup plus que
pour une inquisition fiscale ajoutons qu
aucun salarié ne comprendrait que ceux
qui passent dissimulé réclament les
mêmes avantages que tout en refusant le
moindre droit de regard du fisc deux
fois plus de pommes de terre cette année
que l'année dernière 6 million et demi
de tonnes contre un peu plus de 3
millions en 76 c'est la plus forte
récolte des six dernières années
mais si le consommateur n'est plus dans
la purée les producteurs se demande s'il
ne va pas leur reste et surtout des
épluchures à 20 centimes le kilo à la
production c'est bon pour l'un 10 des
prix c'est mauvais pour les
professionnels qui demandent aux
pouvoirs publics des mesures pour
remédier à l'effondrement du marché par
exemple la fermeture des frontières
l'importation le boom sur la patate
c'est tout de même un événement si vous
avez suivi le feuilleton de son prix
avec nous depuis deux ans et qu'elle a
remplacé la baguette et le litre de lait
comme aliment de base donc comme prix de
référence les habitudes de consommation
des français ont un peu changé la
sécheresse l'an dernier a porté la pomme
de terre sur la montagne des prix fort
mais après l'été pourri de 77 les
tubercules se sont trouvés bien dans
leur peau
nous en regorgent on à tel point que
france inter a lancé une campagne en
leur faveur
c'est ainsi que commencent les riches
heures de la pomme de terre par patrice
drevet
depuis longtemps on n'avait pas vu d'été
comme ça voilà pourquoi depuis longtemps
on n'avait pas vu de pommes de terre
comme ça l'alternance incessantes de
soleil et de pluie a donné des pommes de
terre d'une qualité exceptionnelle
cet été qui était particulièrement ratée
a fait une récolte particulièrement
réussie déjà on entend dire un peu
partout en france que cette année la
pomme de terre à la frite alors
française
à vos paniers
1950 le prix à la consommation est de 27
centimes le kilo 1975 il est de 82
centimes en 25 ans 55 centimes
d'augmentation c'est normal janvier 1977
le prix du kg et de 2 francs et 17
centimes en deux ans un franc et 35
centimes d'augmentation
cet inquiétant la patate est devenu
pomme de terre légumes de l'ue en deux
ans un prix en augmentation de plus de
50% plus quand un quart de siècle du
mois de janvier au mois d'août 77 le
prix est en diminution d'un franc et 33
centimes le kilo la pomme de terre pour
devient la patate à 0,84 curieux destin
que celui de ce légume qui subit les
conséquences de la sécheresse de l'été
76 accentuée par la spéculation de
certains professionnels en effet le prix
des pommes de terre n'est pas établie
par le marché commun mais subit la loi
de l'offre et de la demande
et l'on assiste alors à ce trouble en
bas les européens en 1976 par exemple
exportations françaises massive vers la
belgique qui a acheté pour vendre à la
hollande la hollande a acheté à la
belgique pour vendre à l'allemagne et à
la grande bretagne
en 1977 la production est très bonne 6
millions de tonnes quand on sait que
chaque français consomme 80 kg de pommes
de terre en un an
le calcul est très simple pour savoir
qu'il y aura un excédent d'un million de
tonnes
conséquence de l'été pluvieux originaire
des andes en amérique du sud
on la découvre en europe vers 1550 mais
c'est au xviiie siècle que son usage se
développe en france sous l' influence de
parmentier et au 20e siècle
coluche poursuit son oeuvre monsieur à
des prêts revendiquer comme plat
national par plusieurs pays
elle souffre peut-être du snobisme de
certains offices et souhaite
certainement faire partie elle aussi du
gratte l'espagne n'en finit pas de nous
étonner qui aurait dit il ya un an que
le gouvernement et l'opposition parti
communiste compris pourrait un jour
s'asseoir à la même table et approuvé
ensemble un plan de redressement de
l'économie c'est pourtant ce qui vient
de se passer est le communiste santiago
carillo a pu dire sans doute assez
malicieusement que l'espagne avait
maintenant son programme comme ce n'est
pas le même que celui qui n'a pas pu se
faire en france puisque la droite le
centre les socialistes les communistes
espagnols y ont apposé leur signature
ce compromis historique comme on dit à
l'espagnol prévoit la lutte contre le
chômage à limitation des hausses de
salaires au rythme de l'inflation qui
restera prévu à 22% en contrepartie la
gauche a fait inscrire la révision des
lois agraire un code des droits et des
devoirs du travailleur de l'entreprise
etc
une nouvelle réunion plus politique est
prévue jeudi avec notamment les
questions d'ordre public
entre-temps santiago carillo sera à
l'assemblée du conseil de l'europe à
strasbourg et à son passage à paris
jacques grignon dumoulin l'a rencontré
pour lui demander son sentiment sur le
pacte national souscrit hier je pense
que dans des circonstances qui m'ont
pays s'étant pas énormément important
parce que nous sommes arrivés tous les
forces politiques
à élaborer les lignes générales d'un
programme pour faire face aux problèmes
économiques qui sont en espagne et qui
en réalité décidé tout est compris de la
venise vce démocratie naissante qui est
encore très fragile
alors vous allez à strasbourg quelle est
la position alors du parti communiste
sur l'entrée de l'espagne en europe
qu'est ce que vous en attendez qu est ce
que vous pouvez en dire
vous savez nous sommes pour l'entrée de
l'espagne en europe parce que l'espagne
commence à devenir une démocratie et
l'espagne c'est l'europe
aujourd'hui nous savons tous les sens
comme aignan d'être et européennes et
aucune des avantages alors nous sommes
intéressés à entrer dans des organismes
de l'europe est très me rappelle d'une
classe de l'école qu'il y ait des formes
en ce moment pour être européens à part
entière et non la porte derrière et puis
tous les partis politiques espagnols ont
dénoncé l'attentât commis samedi contre
le président de l'assemblée de biscaye
les extrémistes de letea l'ont abattu au
moment où siégeait la conférence pour le
pacte national cet attentat est dénoncé
comme un complot contre la démocratie et
ses auteurs sont rejeté par l'immense
majorité des espagnols avec vous jean
claude narcy les autres nouvelles de ce
journal réunion spéciale demain du
cabinet israélien autour de menahem
begin qui quittera l'hôpital d'ailleurs
pour participer à cette réunion
mais chez dai hành va présenter aux
autres ministres les propositions
américaines concernant la reprise de la
conférence de genève
ces propositions sont loin de faire
l'unanimité au sein du gouvernement
israélien à new york avant son départ
pour jérusalem chez diana réaffirmé
l'opposition de son gouvernement à
toutes négociations avec l'ol paie ainsi
que la création d'un état palestinien
dans les territoires occupés
et puis aujourd'hui monsieur famille a
été reçue par valéry giscard d'estaing à
l'elysée au cours de l'entretien le
ministre égyptien les affaires
rangèrent rapporté au président français
les conversations qu'il a eues lui aussi
à new york avec jimmy carter et si ayew
devance les deux hommes ont évoqué
ensuite la possibilité de reprise donc
de la conférence de genève sur le proche
orient
l'elysée a vu également la visite du
président gabonais bongo
de passage à paris en route pour new
york où il doit prononcer un discours
devant l'onu en tant que président en
exercice de l'ua
les deux chefs d'état ont évoqué le
conflit ce mali ethiopie et la situation
en afrique australe
les syndicats cgt cfdt fn condamne les
mesures concernant l'immigration en
particulier l'extension de l'aide au
retour
les organisations syndicales estiment
que ces mesures ne sont pas de nature à
mettre un terme au chômage mais qu'elles
sont une atteinte aux droits de l'homme
et aux libertés les plus élémentaires
et pourtant un sondage réalisé récemment
montre que 57% des français sont
favorables à ce que le gouvernement
encourage dans les prochaines années une
diminution de la main d'oeuvre étrangère
dans ce sondage ifop publié demain par
le quotidien de paris
30% des personnes sont indifférentes
tandis que 7% sont hostiles
le maréchal tito sera à paris mercredi
pour une visite officielle de trois
jours lors à trois entretiens en tête à
tête avec valéry giscard d'estaing au
chapitre des conversations la conférence
de belgrade le désarmement et à ce sujet
la france s'apprête à faire des
propositions et puis le dialogue
nord-sud risques de perturbations à la
sncf de vendredi prochain à 4 heures au
dimanche 16 octobre à 6 heures du matin
la fédération générale des agents et non
de conduite appelle les roulant cesser
le travail
motif les salaires et les conditions de
travail
rencontre cgc cnpf les cadres les
patrons aborder les thèmes de la
concertation de la retraites des
salaires et de l'emploi
et sur ce dernier sujet en particulier
pour les cadres de plus de 50 ans la cgc
a demandé que des négociations et bien
lieu afin de trouver une solution
jeudi scheckter a remporté l'avant
dernière épreuve du championnat du monde
de formule 1 le grand prix du canada
profitant des accidents de 1 et 2 andré
ti en fin de course le sud africain a
pris la deuxième place du championnat du
monde derrière niki lauda qui avait
déclaré forfait mais qui est assurée
vous le savez de remporter le titre pour
secousses sismiques en charente maritime
ce matin les habitants des îles d'aix de
ré et d'oléron ainsi que ceux du
littoral ont été réveillés par un
grondement suivi d'une secousse et cela
pendant plusieurs secondes
les chiens ont aboyé pendant plusieurs
minutes et le phénomène n'a causé
heureusement aucun dégât bilan très
lourd dans le sud-est après les pluies
diluviennes de la journée d'hier
plusieurs ponts ont été emportés dans
l'arrière pays des routes sont coupées
pour plusieurs jours des murs et des
parapets se sont effondrés et l'on
essaie aujourd'hui de déblayer au plus
vite
d'ailleurs en italie du nord il ya eu
également des inondations qui ont fait
de nombreuses victimes 15 morts dans le
piémont et on parle de milliards de
lires de dégâts les routes sont
également coupées et les tunnels du
saint bernard et du mont blanc sont
fermés oui et le temps demain et bien il
pleuvra encore en début de matinée sur
l'extrême nord-est et le sud-est plus
puis des éclaircies se développeront sur
le reste du pays le temps sera brumeux
le matin avec des brouillards qui
épargneront toutefois les régions
méditerranéennes et la vallée du rhône
où le mistral et la tramontane
souffleront l'après-midi des éclaircies
apparaîtront sur la bretagne et les
côtes de la manche le temps deviendra
plus nuageux avec des pluies
après un début de manip de matinée à ses
frais les températures maximales seront
ans
et puis j'ajoute une nouvelle jean
claude ascas celle que vous avez donné
tout à l'heure je trouve très
sympathique et très émouvante
initiatives prises à la mémoire des
briques simon lorière le jeune député du
var mort le 21 avril dernier
aymeric simon lorière était un homme de
courage un généreux comme on n'en trouve
plus beaucoup
une association qui porte son nom vient
de se constituer sous la présidence de
monsieur michel debré les membres du
bureau appartiennent à différents
horizons politiques
l'association financera un prix simon
lorière qui récompensera chaque année
une personnalité ou une collectivité
ayant par son action contribuer au
progrès de la justice et de l'équité
sociale
le jury de ce prix comprend notamment
madame simone weil ministre de la santé
jacques blanc secrétaires d'état à
l'agriculture le professeur jean bernard
jean pierre cot député socialiste de
savoie l'architecte ricardo bofill
le cinéaste claude sautet longue vie à
cette association aymeric simon lorière
james bond est de retour un événement
l'espion a quitté ses pantoufles pour
chausser les skis c'est pour le film
espion qui m'aimait c'est roger moore et
il ne se prend pas au sérieux
en avant première avant les salles de
cinéma et avant la saison de ski
voici un nouvel exploit de l'immortel
jazz band
il
1 et à ce moment là
bon ne vous inquiétez pas à ce moment-là
il ouvre son parachute c'est un monsieur
très équipée qui pensaient tous james
bond voilà bonne soirée à tous au nom de
toute l'équipe de tf1 actualité dernier
journal jean pierre pernaut 23h30 merci